wow this is an excellent wine
[Applause]
you're gonna learn how to make great
buys
that tastes like a hundred bucks
[Applause]
the first thing you gotta do is invest
in a corkscrew
i try not to be pretentious about wine
but if you wanna be
i can help you do that also never do
this
tips you always look at the color how to
swirl the glass
just go like this more descriptors
vibrant silky there's tannin structure
that's all part of the game
but at the same time i want you to enjoy
wine
i'm going to take you to tuscany i want
to teach you about the principles
of viticulture the balance in the soil
and microclimate
and why great wines are great
because this is my home we will immerse
ourselves in the tuscan wine making
history
i want to teach you how to really taste
wines i'm using
the 100 point scale i give up to 15
points per color
25 points for aroma 25 points per
structure
and finally 35 points for the overall
quality i have a special
philosophy about food and wine pairing i
like to break the rules
i don't even mind trying white and red
at the same time
and this is a way to really increase
your knowledge understanding
and also confidence with wine it's a
journey
it's an experience i'm james suckling
and this is my master class
you